So you see, even finding formal criteria to tell you if
software is doing something malicious
that you don't want it to do,
that's very difficult, but let's assume you had found those formal criteria.
Now my question for you would be
What would be the problem with automated classification of a program as malware
from a theoretical computer science perspective?
So even if you had formal criteria
that defined exactly what malware is,
so are the issues here that
automated malware detection is an NP complete problem?
Is it automated malware detection undecidable?
Or is it that automated malware detection can never be perfect?
That means you will always have programs that are not malware
that will be classified as being bad
or other programs that are malware
but will basically slip through the net or slip by this program here.